today's national average sits at four
dollars 17 cents the highest on record
and experts say it's only going up from
here
that has a whole lot of people
rethinking their travel plans some even
changing their trips to avoid expensive
flights to las vegas joe muller joining
us now live from the strip with that
story tonight joe
like many others tom d martini comes to
las vegas every single year as prices
continue to rise on those travel related
expenses he says he's now making changes
to his trip
[Music]
what we normally do is we go to the
orleans tom dimartini lives in
pennsylvania we're making about a 10-day
trip he looks forward to his yearly
visit to las vegas the 300
round trip on southwest airlines is now
up to 6.55 rental car
for a week
at a budget rental car
is up to 500 dollars from flight costs
to gas you will need for the car he says
the trip is too expensive he has now
canceled i'm very disappointed
it's something i look forward to every
year he thinks he won't be alone making
changes to vacation plans i even think
about the
the folks coming from
the weekenders coming from los angeles
you're looking at six seven dollar gas
out there already travel expert abby
lagman says during the recession a
decade ago she saw flight surcharges
because of fuel prices then our fuel
prices at the time were skyrocketing she
says she has seen a slight increase
recently but that could go up more at
any time if you are wanting to book a
flight she has a suggestion if you're
ready to go and travel i would
definitely book as soon as possible
dimartini has found a cheaper vacation
we're talking about going in may and
september to atlantic city and
foregoing this trip just because of the
the expense
despite all the price increases aaa
still expects las vegas to be one of the
top destinations for travelers this
spring they say while people won't be
canceling their flights they'll most
likely just be spending less while on
vacation reporting live on the strip
this evening joe muller live local now